Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. Today, we are taking a look at
Firecracker,
a tool for micro VMs that is fast.
Now before we get started, we are just
gonna do some housekeeping.
First and foremost, please subscribe to the YouTube
channel and click the bell. This will get
you alerts all future episodes of Rawkode live
as we cover more and more cloud native
technologies.
Also, if you'd like to chat or you're
not watching this live and have questions, you
can join us in the Discord channel that
is available at Rawkode.chat.
Alright. Now, like I said, today we are
gonna take a look at Firecracker and to
do that, I am joined by Gabriel and
Rawkode from the Firecracker team. Hi there, Gabriel
and Rawkode. How are you both today?
Hello?
We're good?
Yeah.
I always do that. I really need to
get better. I I ask a question and
throw it to people and then have them
content to answer first. So, Gabriel, why don't
you introduce yourself? Tell us who you are,
and then we'll we'll hand it over to
Rado.
Sure.
So first of all, hi, everyone.
My name is Gabriel.
I work as an SD here at AWS,
and I focus
on developing Firecracker.
And, yeah, as David said, today, we're gonna
talk about Firecracker and look at the short
demo on how to use Firecracker at the
end of the stream.
Okay.
Okay. And I'm running on software dev manager.
I've been with Firecracker
since the start. I'm really excited about the
the entire project and even more so about
the the the kind of the space.
I generally view what we're doing as a
as a safe platform for for serverless containers
and functions.
That's just barely a space that's getting started.
So I think it's going to be very
exciting for many years to come.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
Okay. So why don't we start with just
a little bit about Firecracker?
Like,
what
is the the elevator pitch? What what is
Firecracker?
So the elevator pitch is that I assume
what we started with is that you can
do everything you can with containers, but you
can have multitenant isolation.
That's basically what we built it for. And
this is something that
that practically everyone that uses Firecracker
is enabled by.
Like, the classic example are Lambda functions AWS
Lambda functions.
And
the other thing that we're discovering now is
that by kind of having this abstraction layer
at the at the virtualization
level,
very interesting things like like snapshot restore and
and container cloning and things like that start
becoming a possibility.
And this Gabriel will kind of show a
bit of that in his demo.
So that's the
I'd say the elevator pitches that were today,
we're enabling multi multitenant
containers.
And then it looks like we can
facilitate a lot of a lot of dense
utilization
and
just very efficient use of hardware going forward.
Yeah. I think when people traditionally think of
of VMs, we we think of slow cumbersome
processes,
but that's not the case with Firecracker. Right?
It's it's fast, it's late. It's, like, taken
all of the boxes for things that we
need with.
Is it true virtualization
that has does each of the VMs have
its own kernel just like we would traditionally
think of?
So how do we manage to get it?
How did you manage to get it so
fast?
We so it's there's nothing magic about it.
So there's only two things to it. The
the first part is that we
just don't emulate much. And there's the of
the more heavy
devices, it's just network and and block device.
There's also VSOC for for kind of container
control cases.
So Firecracker itself is very small. We we
do rely on the Linux KVM, which does
a lot of things for us. And then
the other thing is that, obviously, there's nothing
stopping you from putting in a huge application
and a huge OS in the guest.
But but our for all our use cases,
our customers
just use very tiny guest kernels and kind
of guest
file systems and so on,
which you you need to do both to
to actually get the the fast and small
effect.
Yeah. So you mentioned that it's powering
land or or or you can power that
kind of use case. What other use cases
are you seeing adopted outside of AWS? Is
that something that people are sharing their stories
with you?
So there's some that we know about.
Yeah. The
there's a list on our website, so let
me just go ahead and reach from that.
Oh, I've got it here. You want me
just to share share my screen?
Yeah. You can share your screen. So it's,
like, right towards the top is the third
paragraph or so.
So
we've made the website open source so people
can add themselves to that list now, and
that's, like, the alphabetically sorted list of people
that use Firecracker.
Of these, some are so Firecracker container deep,
also an Amazon project. And then I think
AppFleet,
KoiWeb,
OpenNebula,
and and
all the Weaveworks stuff, Firecracker and Ignite, those
are actually,
you know, other teams, other organizations that are
using Firecracker to build their their software.
And then containers
and to some extent, also, Weave, Ignite, and
Unique. And those are those are building blocks
that, again, kind of feed into the ecosystem.
All of these things are the use case
that I mentioned at the start. So, basically,
multitenant
containers or functions
with very low resource overhead.
Alright. Awesome. Well, I'm very excited to be
playing with it today. So we're we're gonna
run through getting started with Firecracker.
In preparation for this, I have spun up
Ubuntu machine on Equinix Metals. This is the
bare metal
Linux machine,
and I can say hello here.
This is a unmodified
vanilla Ubuntu 20 o four machine.
So we'll walk through the entire process of
getting Firecracker working on this machine
and cover some of those use cases that
Raghu mentioned as well.
So we're gonna work through the getting started
guide from the GitHub repository, which people can
find at firecracker dash micro v m slash
firecracker.
You mentioned earlier, Raghu, there's kinda getting started
here in the read me and then there's
more within the documentation,
like, should we start? Will it be right
on this one here?
I think all
the Gabriel address studies got
a better grasp on it than I do.
Yes. So
the getting started section
is a good place to take a look
at how Firecracker works.
And if you look at the
that there's a sentence which starts with the
Firecracker binary,
there's also another link there which says you
can go to the quick start guide.
But do go over the getting started guide
first and
Okay. So you want me to go to
the quick start guide first?
No. Start with the getting started section, and
then we can go to the quick start
guide. Okay. So I'm assuming we probably
don't need to build it. We can just
grab the release batteries.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
And this is AMD
sixty four.
There we go.
I forgot how to curl for a second
there.
Okay. So we have two binary files here,
Firecracker zero twenty four and
JLR.
Can you give us a quick TLDR on
these on what these are?
Yep. So the
Firecracker
binary is Firecracker itself,
which is the VMM that launches
virtual machines.
And the jailer is
you can record it as a
safety feature, which we recommend to run together
with Firecracker.
It has the role of
locking Firecracker inside the network test spaces
so that you can have an extra isolation
boundary
whenever you're running multiple
micro VMs on one post.
The purpose of this
isolation
would be to, for example, mitigate the risks
whenever
sandboxes escape might happen from a micro VM,
and that
can be, for example,
try to bring down all the Firecracker processes.
Alright.
It's an interesting user and group ID. This
is downloaded with as well. I don't think
I've ever seen it that high before.
I'll just ignore that for now.
Okay. So we've got our binaries. Let's jump
back to our guest. Start to gauge.
We don't wanna build Sorry.
Can I have one thing? Yeah. Of course.
Go.
So so one thing to mention here is
that we definitely want we wanted to add
the virtualization layer as an isolation boundary, but
we wanted to keep everything that was already
kind of a
standard practice in the container world. So that's
why we also have this JLR, which applies
all the usual namespaces and c groups and
seccomp and things like that.
So we're we basically kinda wanted to add
a security layer, not replace
all the usual ones that Linux offers.
Okay. Awesome. Thanks.
Alright. Let's click on this quick start gate.
Think we grabbed the bang and erase, so
we can skip over that. We also need
to make sure that we have KVM available
on our kernel.
Alright.
Let's just run a quick update first.
Let's see.
Linux tools KVM.
There's some modules.
Yeah. Let's try the Linux Toast KVM. I
don't suppose either of you know if that's
correct before I start.
Yeah. I'm sure it'll be okay.
That was a nervous confidence in my voice,
but I'm sure it'll be it'll be fine.
It's added to service.
What's
it called?
Okay. I think you can just check for
the dev k, you know, file descriptor.
Yep.
So that's what that's what we need to
see. Right?
Yep.
Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Nice.
We've got the binary
and now we can
are the access access settings correct for for
the I think for the KPM?
I think there was a step to
David is running as a route. So Yeah.
I'm running as route. So I
just assumed I'd be able to
do anything.
Sure we'll find out pretty quickly.
Yeah.
Okay. So,
let me try and understand
what's going on here. So we have to
run. Is the Firecracker binary going to run
some sort of daemon process that runs on
the host? That's kinda what I'm guessing here
by the fact that it's gonna create a
socket for us to communicate with.
Yes. I see you nodding. Okay.
Yeah. Exactly.
Whenever you want to start a Firecracker
instance, you first need to run that
command line that that command there, which says
Firecracker dash dash API sock.
The point there is to create an UDS
socket,
which is used to
instruct that Firecracker instance to,
for example,
set the number of ECUs,
set the amount of memory for your micro
VM, and all the all the properties that
you may want to put into for that
micro VM to run.
So now there's
there's an extra step that you need to
do. You need to launch another terminal,
or perhaps you can launch this next TMX
session and
have
Yeah. I know those terminals. Okay. We'll just
leave that that process running.
Yeah. And we'll pop over here.
Something that may not be super obvious, the
the general
approach that we have is that there's one
Firecracker process
per VM. So there's not a single control
process for all of them.
Kind of part of the security architecture, there's
a one to one mapping. Oh, nice. And
all of all of the vCPU threads are
basically
threads within that process.
Okay. So does that mean that the API
sock that we've actually specified here is kind
of arbitrary, and I would just create a
new socket for each of the virtual machines.
Right? Got it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got it.
Like
a thousand VMs, you only you have a
thousand of these to talk to.
Cool. I don't I mean, if if we're
feeling brave, we can spin up a thousand
VMs on this. Well, sure. But maybe not
necessary just now. I think I did throw
some sizable hardware at it actually.
Yeah. We've got 64 cores and 300 250
gig of RAM. We can run a few.
Alright. So Actually
actually, it depends on what you run inside
of micro v m.
If you don't run a lot of user
space processes inside of micro v m, you
can launch a fairly large number of micro
v ms
Because the memory is not allocated
before startup,
each page fault allocates a small chunk of
memory, which is added for that Firecracker process.
Alright.
Okay. So we have our second shell.
Can I just copy and paste this? No.
You skipped a step which says that you
should download a kernel and root file system.
Yep. You're right.
Download these.
You're running a Next 86 machine. Right? You
should be clicking. Yep. Those two.
Okay. FSL.
This is our kernel
and we also need our Rufus.
So I'm assuming these
this this kernel and Rufus that I've got
here are really just for kind of
playing around purposes
rather than something I would
actually run. I think these are for,
yeah, the for our guy for the quick
start guide, and Yeah. They may be used
in some of the tests as well. This
is one area where we're working on now.
We need to get a a more kind
of a comprehensive
method of of posting
test resources
because they're starting to get more combinations of
test cases. But, yeah, I think right right
now, these these will do. Is there tooling
available for people that wanna build their own,
you know, kernel and root file systems?
Is that difficult for people to do or
is it just cumbersome but trivial?
For for kernels,
it's pretty straightforward
as long as you take a look at
our kernel config file that we we host
on the on the repository.
For the time system, it's a bit more
complicated.
We do point at the guide in our
in our quick start guide somewhere.
But
it's
it's it's not completely
it's it's not a nice root file system
that you can, for example,
use to store kernel modules. It's a simple
system that you
build based upon a container,
and then you can use it to start
up micro VMs.
So to answer your question, we as I
just said, we are working on this,
and I think that pretty soon we will
be providing
a nicer method of of building root file
systems.
I mean, would it be possible to use
container images as the root file system and
inject the kernel?
That's exactly what we do, actually. Alright.
So, for example,
you can spin up a an I find
container,
install all the packages that you want,
and then simply dump that that
request to a
Alright.
Alright. Well, let me
copy this.
It's gonna be an ISH
and a nice friendly bang.
And I called this kernel
and I called this riff.
And then we have a image
bucket URL
then does a detection
of
is this trying to download the root fail
system in kernel?
Yeah. It actually downloads them.
Yeah. Alright. Okay.
So we could just save this.
Yeah. I I don't think we need that.
Alright? We Yeah. We don't need that.
Alright. Okay. Because we download it manually, we
can okay. Got it. Yeah. The
second step actually uses them.
Okay. So that's it. Alright.
We'll go through this in a second. Let
me paste this in.
I've already got a main. I'm gonna be
horrible and call it main too.
Okay.
So what we have here is we're working
at the architecture again.
I need to replace this with
kernel
And
because we already know the architecture, can just
clean this up. Right? So it's a bit
easier.
Really should have used that.
There we go.
Okay. So this is curling
through Unix socket where we have our Firecracker
daemon process running.
It is using a put.
Okay. So the Firecracker daemon is exposing an
http
style API
where we can post the or put
the images into.
And then we specify
is this just a kernel bit parameters. Right?
Yep. Mhmm. Okay.
I understand some of this.
Can I just run main two?
Yep.
And we got two zero four, which is
success, no content, I believe. So
that worked?
Yes.
Now we should you should follow
the next step and set root file system.
Alright.
Fine. I started about pressing them anyway. So
we called this change to
root f s,
and we're just doing the exact same
again.
We got a two zero four, that's good.
And then this starts the machine, so there's
some sort of actions endpoint where we can
send commands to it.
Alright.
I'm not gonna bother saving this one to
the script.
This is no local fail.
Yep.
Done. They have a VM?
Yes.
But you need to switch back to the
other terminal.
Oh, look at that. So
the reason why you had to switch back
to the other terminal
was that because you launched the initial Firecracker
process in this terminal here,
the standard DNS, standard out handlers
are still kept by this
terminal instance.
Okay. So so this is the serial console
of that machine, basically. Yeah.
I'm assuming as there are flags I can
pass into that initial Firecracker call to just
have it run detached there in the background?
If you use the jailer, yes. You can
detach it and
output the serial console to death mode, for
example.
Okay. I'm assuming I can log in as
Rut. Is that the next step in the
docs? Should I pay attention?
No. Okay.
So what's worth mentioning is that, you know,
there's nothing
Firecracker is we're we try to make it
kind of just behave as a regular process
so you can do all the regular things.
And in this instance, you know, I think
the the dealer does more fancy things to
start it in the background. But
in this case, it's just using
share the input and output connected to the
terminal.
So that's it.
K. If I type password, will it log
me in, or is it
It's Root. Root. That that was guess too.
Okay.
And this is just Alpine Linux?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. You you don't have a network
interface here set up. You need to follow
another guide if you want to have a
network interface set up.
Okay. But I do have a
full Alpine Linux virtual machine running on my
bare metal.
So that's pretty cool.
Awesome.
So out of the box then, Firecracker
doesn't ship with any networking, so I'd have
to configure this device to be able to
connect to the network.
Does Firecracker expose any hooks or extension points
for, like,
desks and storage or
local mounts or anything like that?
No. No. So so I I wanted to
call out two things. So first of all,
it's it it'll be worth looking at the
memory usage or the Firecracker process
now and maybe after after we do something
in this Alpine. And then the other one
is
by itself, Firecracker just kind of gives you
a a number of commands that you can
then use to create tap devices and
those connect those to a network and that
you can use to map block devices and
then mount those inside the guest.
So
we're we're basically
the the the whole idea is to have
a very low level I guess, in in
some term, low level API that that
just hands over all the all the, let's
say, the decisions to the local orchestrator on
the host. Now there are there are high
level libraries. There is a Go SDK,
and there's a
integration with Firecracker container d to kind of
move things up the stack. But at these
at this level, it's just connecting things to
the HTTP API,
and we'll have to create those resources separately.
So, like, if we want a network, we
need to create a tap device.
If we want a file system, need to
create a file and format it as a
file system and then and map it to
the to the Firecracker process.
K. Yeah. That makes a lot of sense.
Definitely.
Alright.
Let's should I go back to our our
docs?
What this is saying here?
Is that we have our TTY if I
take this login and password route and route.
When you're done issuing a reboot command and
say the guest will actually shut down Firecracker.
Okay.
And by default, our Firecracker VM gets one
virtualized CPU and a 28
meg of
RAM.
Cool.
And so what was it you said there,
Roger? You wanted us to look at the
memory consumption of the process?
Oh,
I think you've messaged yourself.
It should be around less than what's actually
configured
due to the mechanism that Gabriel mentioned below.
It basically only demand falls on the the
needed pages.
Okay.
So what's our next step here then? Do
we is there more I think
that's just the building Firecracker. Right? Okay.
So do we want to do anything with
this Alpine virtual machine? Should we move on
to a different
tutorial?
What do you think is best?
So there's kind of two ways we can
go. We can go through the network and
the block device tutorial to give it a
network and the block device and do things
with it. Mhmm.
Mhmm. We I guess we can also kind
of skip to
Gabriel's demo. He's using the the Go SDK,
right,
to to show a snapshot use case.
Okay.
So there's quite a lot in the documentation
page here.
So Yeah.
The maybe I can talk through a few
other things. So the the thing that's helpful,
just to kinda explain the
That
that would be great.
So the
as you mentioned with the network, the
we have kind of a tenant for for
being very minimal and only implementing the very
basic things we need. And for example, if
you look at most container workloads and most
things like function, like, function,
They just kind of have used the network
mostly, and sometimes they use the disk.
And so we only implemented those two devices.
And then we right now, there's very simple
back end. So for network,
it's just a Linux tap device, and you
need to precreate that tap interface
and wire it up, you know, as you
wish on your host.
And then
and then
you'll have that network interface into the guest.
You can have as many of these as
you want, and then you you can create
files and format them as as as file
systems.
And, again, you can map those as block
devices to to a Firecracker process,
and they'll show up as drives in the
in the guest that you must then mount.
Obviously, in, you know, in in real use
cases, all of these are
are done once and then, you know,
happen every time. Yep.
And then kind of you this is the
primitive you use to set up your
for example, if you wanna use a container
ecosystem,
this would somehow be equivalent to run c.
So it's, like, even under
the kind of container d layer.
And, hopefully, one of the things we're working
towards is to make this seamless. So, like,
if you wanna use it with containers,
you'll never be at this level where we're
at now. You'll you'll kind of operate from
from the container d level. There's also a
Firecracker tool
in the in the
in the Firecracker microvmorg,
and,
yeah, that's that's kind of the the perspective.
And so our
focus is just on getting the primitive capabilities
be really useful.
That's kind of kind of why we mentioned
memory.
The
desire is that you have basically memory over
subscription by default, which is what you have
with every every Linux process. You know, the
OS manages the memory for you. Right now,
this is half true. You we we only
demand full page memory in, but then we
never give the memory back by default.
There's a ballooning feature, which kind of
again, the the system users can use to
deflate the memory of the
of the
Firecracker VM.
And snapshotting also affects
memory utilization a lot, and we'll see that
in in Gabriel's demo.
And then the other thing is just to
to kind of get out of the way
and start very fast.
Right now,
of booting a simple OS takes a hundred
and a bit milliseconds with that kernel, and
then you're kind of in user space.
Then depending on what you do in user
space, it can take, you know, a second
or a hundred milliseconds or ten seconds.
Yep. And
snapshotting should also re resolve this by kind
of resuming
to the point where you snapshot before very
fast.
And those are kind of the two core
properties that that Firecracker is basically built to
resolve while keeping everything secure and then integrating
up the stack, which is definitely an area
we're still working with on.
Okay. I can I ask a couple can
I ask a couple?
Oh. I can hear myself. I can hear
myself.
It's weird. Oh, it's gone.
Okay.
So I'm gonna ask a couple of really
naive questions then. So if I were to
just
if I were to shut down this Firecracker
deeming that is exposing this socket here,
Everything goes away. There's there's no nothing saved.
It's completely ephemeral. It just goes away. I
spin up a new one. I get a
completely fresh Alpine Linux.
Okay.
I'm assuming
based on the kind of the socket and
HTTP API that you're showing to me that
if I just pull up the
no.
Maybe one of my weird brush main files
there.
Yeah. Here,
when we talk about the networking capabilities and
those, you know, creating desks that we can
pass in, are those just additional parameters here
on this or very similar to this?
There's a different API for every resource. There's
a file in in the docs that's kind
of generated from from our API server,
which has the full API.
Right.
I think it's it's in Swagger format, so
it should be ingestible by clients.
Some of the existing clients, I believe, are
generated from that.
Okay.
Yeah. That makes sense. Top. Sorry. Where was
it?
In the a
I might be wrong, but I think it's
there. Yeah. It's in
No. You're you're searching for the slider file.
You could just
use the GitHub feature, which says go to
file. There's a button
on your right.
Yep. Go to file. Yep. And type Swagger.
Yep. And that's the one.
Alright. So this is just a completely documented
API for that socket that has been available
to us.
Yeah. And there's a network resource there, which
has all the networking options.
Okay. You also mentioned there was a fire
CTL,
fire control, fire cuddle, like, all the different
variations.
Does that make working against that HTTP API
a lot simpler? Is that just mapping gets,
puts, deletes, etcetera, to make it feel more
like like, your control, for example?
It's
the kind of application that you would use
to
simply start the Firecracker instance by giving the
Firecracker binary a kernel and
root file system, and then everything will start
up for you.
So,
yes,
if if if you are wondering what it
does behind the scenes is that it wraps
all the API calls that you just did
using the terminal.
Okay. Awesome.
Well, why don't we move over to
Gabriel's machine and take a look at a
demo that is
hopefully
a bit more interesting than my airplane one
and But that was really cool. I love
just how fast it is
And I like the architecture with the daemon
and stuff like that. I think it was
just
such a cool project.
Okay. We can see your Versus code
now.
Yep.
So
in this demo, I'm going to show you
one of my favorite Firecracker features,
which is the feature.
So
to to to show the demo, I'm using
200 line
snippet of of written in Go.
Could you just drag that window a a
little bit bigger and
zoom in the font a wee bit, please?
Yep.
And actually the whole the whole window just
so it goes to the correct kinda aspect
ratio. I think I'll just make it a
bit easier.
One second.
Yeah. Perfect. That's the one.
Okay.
Thanks.
Alright. So
wrapping around the all the CRL request that
David did, I'm using Firecracker SDK.
This
component is one of the
open source projects which you can find in
the Firecracker
ecosystem.
So if you if you want to take
a look at it, you just simply go
to to the to its GitHub page
and take a look at it.
And, yeah, this is this is basically the
all all that I'm using
to to make the demo simpler.
For the micro that I'm launching, I'm gonna
use a few simplified assumptions,
and I'm not going to
customize the number of CPU or the or
the memory size. I'm using only two DCQs
for my micro
VMs, and I'm using
four gigabytes
micro VMs.
And for the current parameters,
I'm simply using what we
put in the quick start guide.
And these two files here are taken exactly
from the quick start guide, and they're the
same that they did use.
And then I also have the Firecracker banner,
which I'll beat myself from from the main
branch.
I'm going to skip over this code, and
I'm going to look at the flags that
I've added for the demo.
So
the first
flag
simply
the branches in microphone given a UDS packet.
That's what it does. You just,
like, test that socket and then a microgenomic
response.
And then as I was saying, we're going
to take a look at the snapshot feature.
So
one
the the the first snapshot related parameter is
two snapshots,
which saves the the the microgame state to
the snapshot file.
And then the second
will load the microgame from the snapshot file.
So yeah.
That's that's the demo.
One other thing that I wanted to add,
the Firecracker request, the
current version
of Firecracker request doesn't
support those notes
feature,
but I will add it as a PR
after this demo.
So
here we have the Firecracker binary and the
precompiled
launcher.
So that's just
well, that's just come.
So this is what I showed earlier.
So let's right now, we're launching MicroVM using
socket file called one dot sock.
Not very creative here.
And, yeah, this is the micro view. As
you saw, it launched pretty quick.
I didn't have any timing features here, but,
visually, it doesn't it didn't look like
any major
time or waste even the operations happened there.
So let's do something this micro VM so
that we can save its state.
One very simple
thing that we can do is to put
a message on the
the message
profile.
So let's just say echo
state one
to dev
key message.
And now if we look at the kernel
app, we can see the screen saved here.
So, yeah, right now, we can
save the micro VM state.
So what was the syntax?
So to save the micro VM state, I
first need to tell it what socket is
because all the HTTP
request will be sent to this socket.
And now I'm going to tell it to
save the snapshot file,
and let's just call that snapshot file state
one.
And so
for the for the two snapshots
operation, I've added the the
time measurement
line, which simply measures how long it took
to save the snapshot feature.
And for this operation,
it took two hundred and eighty milliseconds.
It's
not much, but
it's not less either.
We we will see that
if we do another snapshot, it will take
less. And I'm not going to explain
why that happens right now.
So we see again that it's one nineteen
milliseconds.
So
let's go a little bit what happened when
we created this snapshot.
So Firecracker has two ways of creating snapshot.
One way is a full snapshot, and another
way is a deep snapshot.
So a full snapshot simply saves everything
in the micro VM. So, for example, if
you run a full snapshot on a micro
VM,
all the memory contents will be saved to
disk.
What happens when we run a deep snapshot?
Well, a deep snapshot simply
saves the dirty pages that have been
used by the micro view,
which is why
the second snapshot took less.
So what's happened after the first snapshot
was that
we we created the file and all the
pages were marked as clean.
And then all subsequent pages that were detected
as dirty was safe were safe in state
two.
And I
guess we can look at the sizes of
the files. Right? Yes. Exactly.
And one side effect of saving less information
is that we save less we we write
less data to disk.
So if we take a look at the
two
memory files,
LS simply tells us that, okay, both files
are four gigabyte in size,
but they're actually not because these are sparse
files.
And if we take a look
at the files using the u,
we can see that
state one document has
one seventy one megabytes in size,
and state two document has only 348
k,
which is
magnitude
of
part of less than than the state one.
So
that's
that's the reason, you know, micro view from
the first snapshot.
So what we do we're doing right now
is that we are launching the second micro
PM. We could create a socket at a
file called
two dot sock.
And we will going to be using
state one on the for the first snapshot.
There's a
there's a a
short simplifying assumption that they took here,
which is the fact that we are dumping
two files here. One one is the memory
file, and the second one is the disk
content.
So we've launched the second microgame, and we've
restored it from a snapshot.
The performance
says that it took only fifteen milliseconds.
This is on my laptop, and it also
includes the overwork and that Firecracker for SDK
purposes.
Typically, in production environments,
we target about nine milliseconds,
and you can also see that in our
test.
I can show you the data.
So now let's check that
this micro VM on the right was actually
started from the snapshot that was created from
first micro VM.
And we can do that by looking at
the message,
and we can see the state file
the state one message here.
These these messages are are due to the
fact that we are using in front of
from and
timekeeping is not
in in in sync with the other micro
view.
Oh, yeah. This is it.
Nice. Thank you. Now I'm trying to stop
the micro again. Yeah. And it starts.
I can publish this and send you
links later if you guys want to take
a look.
Awesome.
That's very cool. I like seeing how that
snapshot all comes together and how
it's just how quick everything is. I think
that's a
really I think that just opens up so
much possibilities for the applications of Firecracker
for so many different domains that I hadn't
even thought of before we come into today's
session. Hold on. Let me pop this back
over to.
It's such a really cool technology.
I'm curious then as what we've seen today
is like Firecracker deeming as opposed to an
HTTP API. I can communicate with that HTTP
API
to do all of this cool stuff. So
this is quite low level and you kind
of touched on this earlier rather.
So now the plan that this technology exists
and that's already done all these cool things.
Let's just the build all of these abstractions
on top of it now.
Can people get involved?
Like, you know, you know, people watch this
because that's really cool. I wanna help. Like,
what's the best way for them to do
that?
Yeah. So there's there's already a few things
that are started. So the Go SDK and
the
right now, at least from from from what
we've seen, looking around
in an integration with container d is probably
a really good avenue to make this available
to more people.
And both of these things are project that's
that are already there, and people can contribute
to them. I think there's definitely
to dos. They're in the same kind of
organization
as Firecracker. So there's a Firecracker dash micro
v m. There's other
folks that have done other integrations, like Weaveworks
has
Weave Ignite.
So
I think that at this point, there is
actually more than one answer.
We're we're really
open to everything. We're trying to support all
of the
all of the integrations.
So, yeah, I think there's a there's a
variety of of projects to to pick from,
you know, on which to contribute.
We're definitely open to pull requests for Firecracker
itself, though
we
we tend to be, like, laser focused on
actually not having a lot of features.
So we're just kinda working backwards from our
use case all the time. And if we
don't need it, then we're we're not gonna
build it.
But, yeah, at the same time, you know,
people there's a there's a bunch of activity
now in the space of
of virtual machine managers. So there's a bunch
of other projects if if people kind of
like virtualization that they can that they can
get involved with.
Alright. Awesome. Alright. We do have one question
that is not in here from Michael who's
asking,
what are the ways to pass a desired
IP configuration
to the Firecracker VM?
I'll pass that to Gabriel, I think.
Yeah. Sure.
So
I I'm trying to understand
the the exact question.
Yeah. Can I do you mind if I
rephrase it? Michael, I'm gonna just make some
assumptions on what I think you're asking. But
I can imagine a situation where I wanna
run multiple Firecracker virtual machines and probably have
them communicate with one another. So, like, is
it possible for me to create a,
you know, some sort of bridge network device
and then have all of the Firecracker VMs
have an IP on a pre allocated CIDR
for that kind of network?
Right. So
first of all, you
don't have a way of
forcing the Firecracker
micro VM. Actually, the the the
user space inside the micro VM to have
an IP a certain IP interface.
You can only do that through configurations.
So stepping back a bit, yes, as you
you mentioned,
perhaps, to create 10 type interfaces
and connect each Firecracker instance to one type
interface.
And from this point on, after the start
of Firecracker,
you
have multiple options. You can, for example, have
a
running on that on that Linux bridge and
have the request issues at at startup time.
One
other
doing it is the MMDS feature.
The MMDS feature, I don't think I've mentioned
it so far.
It's like a
scaled down version of IMDS,
which is basically a way of putting metadata
inside
Hyper VM. And then when you issue
HTTP request to certain IP addresses, you will
get both of that metadata.
And
you can use this metadata, for example, to
create a maybe a system d service, which
starts at large time and get that information
from
from the storage.
Alright.
Yeah. I think that makes sense. You you
dropped it a little bit there, but I
think what you were suggesting is the first
option would be to have a a tap
device per VM and have it boot from
a DHCP server and allocate the IP that
way. And the alternative way would be to
run a process via system d that could
have a metadata API passing
some identification and then get back an IP
address and configure the device that way.
Yeah. So under under getting the actual IP
address, you can be as creative as possible.
You
have
lots of ways to do it, so
you're you're not bound to these two options.
Yeah.
Yeah. Just have an NTP server and hash
it, make up an IP address. That's what
I'm gonna do. Exactly. So so as an
example of something that's let's say, that we're
using our test, but it's not entirely crazy
if you wanna
kind of shave milliseconds off the start time.
You can you can basically
use the like, some segment of the MAC
address, which you can configure when you configure
the the tap
sorry. The network device where it via the
socket, you can give it a MAC address.
And then you can, by convention, between the
host and the guest,
have that have some bytes of the MAC
address or some hash of it with the
IP.
Only this in our test just because it
was simple, but
these I'm not saying this particular approach, but
these kind of approaches
will be often very useful if you wanna
start super fast.
The
vision is basically that
we get to the point where the fact
that you're getting VM isolation
just doesn't get it in the way of
your workload at all. So on on Gabriel's
laptop, it was fifty milliseconds to start from
a snapshot.
As you mentioned, it's kind of nine on
a on a on a server grade machine.
And
there's
like, on ARM, it's even faster. It's two
point five milliseconds.
Wow. And, you know, we've done some there's
some crazy optimizations that are nowhere near
production. But down the line, we see this
number going to one millisecond.
And at that point, you basically
this is just a VM. So, again, you
need to start the the things inside it
will resume exactly where they left off,
but we're actually
just
walking a few steps back. All of this
is in that preview, so don't use snapshotting
production.
We need to it actually it actually works
very well, like, as a technology, but we
need to address the security issue, which is
that that that the thing where that cable
did where he started a machine from a
state. You can do that a thousand times,
and not only can you do it, but
it's desirable to do it because you can
start, like, at a, like, pre warmed JVM
application state.
But right now, we don't have a easy
solution for
the security issues that would be introduced by
cloning all the random things
and just by actually, you know, having RNGs
in the same state and so on.
K. And we're we're working on that with
the we have some patches for the system
d,
team that will allow us to
then further down the stack or up the
stack, integrate with OpenSSL and the JVM and
so on,
for these systems to kind of figure out
that they've been restored from a snapshot and
do whatever it is they need to do
to become safe again,
but that's not there yet. So until that's
there, this is like a cool demo feature,
but nothing more. Don't don't use this in
production.
Okay. I mean, every time someone tells me
not to do something in production, I always
get an overwhelming urge to go and do
it. But I will I I promise I
will try not to. Okay. We for compelling.
So so you can, like, literally start thousands
of VMs in something like, you know, twenty,
thirty seconds, and they're all up and you
go SSH to all of them. And they
take, like, no memory because it only false
the pages that are being used at that
moment by the, like, thing running in them
at the moment. It every all the memory
that was dirty during view, boot, and setup
and everything is not brought back into physical
memory. It is it is very, very efficient.
Nice.
Okay.
What I I I really wanna experiment with
running FTD and a Firecracker with the snapshots
and and spending that backup. That to me
just seems like a really, really cool use
case. But we do have some more audience
questions, so we'll run through these, and then
I'll let you get back to your day.
So,
we have a couple more networking things, but
Nerd has asked, is there an option to
hook into IPAM utilities to provide IP addresses
without DHCP?
I guess that this depends on how you're
building your service.
I'm not exactly sure on how IPAM works.
But
if you build your service in such a
way that you can access it from the
micro VM, then I I suppose that you
you could hook it up.
Alright.
We'll come back to that. I I don't
know if there is a good answer to
that to be fair, so we'll move on
just now, but thanks for the question there.
Michael's back and asking if there were any
docs on option two. So do you have
any canonical
implementations of that, like, system d metadata
IP address thing? Is that something that you
do internally, or is it the documentation?
We don't have any
any
proof of concept that that uses it, but
I I think that we can provide some
information on how to do it.
If you take a look at the
MMTS
documentation inside the Firecracker repository,
it's pretty well explained on how to create
a request
and how to get the metadata from there.
And from that point on,
whether you're using system d or OpenRC or
any unit system that you like, you can
adapt it to to your environment.
Yeah. I mean, I guess
I I wanna make sure that my understanding
of it is not, you know, completely silly,
but it's it's really just a script that
runs on the VM. It has an HTTP
endpoint that says, I am this thing. Give
me some an IP address, and it's literally
just configuring it as, a standard Linux interface.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So so so, actually,
other
the the the thing that we mostly do
is just try to create this very much
not in your way virtualization layer. And after
that, you have a Linux system, and you
do what you will what you need with
it. Yeah. And what this is, a conscious
decision. We were very supportive, and and some
of those other projects that I mentioned are
kind of developed by peer teams of ours.
But
and we'll definitely altogether invest in making it
easy to actually run, you know, containers or
entire Kubernetes pods with my MicroVim isolation. But
for Firecracker itself, it's just like a box
with strings, and then you can attach them
to what you need based on use case.
We're definitely gonna support any other
integrations that are not, you know, from from,
you know, from Firecracker container deal and all
of that. So I think that's actually a
positive that it's kinda more tedious to get
started at this level, for sure, but you
can do anything you want with it. And
I think there's integrations with Nomad and things
like that, which are not, you know, the
the regular
Kubernetes
path.
Okay. We'll just run through two more.
So we got a question here asking,
could
we use Firecracker and Kubernetes with Kubernetes networking?
Is this something that we've ignite does already?
Yeah. So I I don't have the full
answer, but it's there's two things that we
we've just done. There's Weave Ignite, which basically
kinda has a docker like interface
for Firecracker
VMs. And then there's Firecracker,
which I believe just does Kubernetes
pods with Firecracker isolation.
And then there's also Kata containers,
which runs Kubernetes
pods with VM isolation.
And I think they have an option for
Firecracker
or Cloud Hypervisor,
if I'm correct. I am I need I
need to check up on the full list,
but they have a number of VMs that
you can use, Firecracker included.
So those are the I think, like, the
strict Kubernetes integrations that I'm aware of. And
then there's also, as I mentioned,
Nomad, and I think OpenNebula is something in
this direction as well just to get your
workload running with VM isolation.
Alright.
I just wanna say that I I, you
know, I love this technology, but you only
need it if you actually
like, if you have a single kind of
single trust boundary in your application, then you
don't need to segregate like this. It's it's
more trouble than it's worth.
But if you have, like, a big machine
and, you know, you wanna run workloads from
10 customers or even, like, teams in your
in your own organization and you don't want
the their, you know, their binaries of knowing
about each other, then this is this is
basically what we're working towards. We wanna make
this easy and very, very secure.
Okay.
So we also got a question asking about
any
idea about snapshotting support in Kubernetes?
I'm not entirely sure what's been asked there,
but do you? Do you wanna throw an
answer at that?
Yeah.
I can
so I there the only thing that I'm
aware of is that there is a a
project called CRIU,
which is about kind of snapshotting the the
runtime of a container. Okay. And we've briefly
synced up with them on the Snapseed thing
to make sure that the approach works for
both.
But other than that, I I don't know
of of anything else. I think in the
long run, we definitely want
every that uses Firecracker to take advantage of
this. I'm hoping this will become the standard
because it is once we once we figure
out all the kind of security implications and
solve them and make them easy,
I think this is by far the best
way. You literally get
I think, you know, I think it's realistic
to just start entire pods in a few
milliseconds. You kind of warm them up once,
snapshot them, and then you just have almost
instant startup times everywhere.
But I think that's a couple of years
off at this point. K. Thank you for
that.
Nerd, I do see your other comments on
IPAM.
Hopefully, Gabriel can get to those after
the show for comments or whatever or anyone
else that's watching that has that knowledge. We'll
finish with question then, which is
well, then a simple one, but is there
any managed Firecracker
and
Deepak? Is that something that AWS offer,
or is that just Lambda?
Yeah.
Yeah. So there's no there's no, like, managed
Firecracker
instances or anything like that.
You'll be implicitly using fire you you'll be
running in a Firecracker micro VM if you're
on a Lambda function or for some types
of Fargate containers
today.
And, yeah,
there's as as I mentioned in the beginning,
there's a bunch of other integrations with open
source tools. You can take a look at
that.
Alright. Well, thank you, audience, for all of
those questions. We are gonna call that there,
though. Raider and Gabriel, thank you so much
for joining me today. That's a that snapshot
on demo was awesome.
Walking through that getting started was also great.
Just seeing how quick that was to do.
This is a really cool technology. Hopefully, people
will have their interest piqued and will check
it out. And please check out the GitHub
repository, contribute where you can. There's lots to
be done.
Thank you again. Have a wonderful afternoon, and
I'll speak to you, Boston.
Thank you as well. Bye. Thank
you.